Another question we had about relational databases were about joins.
Specifically, how you do a lot of more complicated queries without joins,
because that seems pretty fundamental to a lot of database administrators.
Yes. Joins are fundamental to databases and particularly SQL databases, and I said don't use joins.
Now, a lot of this is opinion, but it's based on experience.
The reason I say don't use joins is because joins don't scale very well.
If you're writing a typical web problem where you think you're going to have lots of data,
and that data is going to eventually need to be spread across multiple machines,
running queries that involve multiple tables joining these two large pieces of data together,
or potentially more than two, across multiple machines is very, very difficult.
There's a lot of research going on to make that possible,
but with the consumer tools, it's not going to work very well for you.
You're going to have to figure out something on your own.
Now, if you structure your data in such a way that everything is independent,
you don't have to worry about that. Things scale a lot nicer.
You have to take this into account when you start, though.
You need to think of your databases as basically these large key value stores,
and you're not going to be able to do complex queries.
You're going to look up things by ID or maybe look up things by single coms,
but you're not going to be joining things together.
Now, one of the things you have to do there then is store some redundant data.
If you have your data nice and normalized--
that is, all of the table for a particular type is in a table for that type--
and you join everything together at query time, that's a nice-looking database,
but as soon as you break things apart you might need to store--
effectively kind of cache other pieces of data in other tables.
On Reddit, we store a users karma, I think, on a link they submit it,
so we have that piece of data handy, so we don't have to fetch the user and the lnk
and all that sort of stuff.
It means there's some more maintenance overhead.
When you do an insert--when you update a particular field--you may have to update it
in a couple places, but that to me is easier--a little bit more easy to manage
than trying to figure out how do you run joins across large datasets
across multiple machines.
Now, if you have a small dataset and if it's on one machine, great. Use joins.
Do what works for you.
On Hipmunk, for example we have a database of hotels. It's 300,000 entries long.
It's not getting any bigger, because that's about how many hotels there are in the world.
We use joins in that database. It makes the problem easier.
But on Reddit, we have databases of links and comments and votes.
Those tables can have more than 1 billion rows.
We're not doing joins on those tables.
Those are spread across many machines just to make the queries work.
Again, use what makes sense.
If you're going to be storing lots of data, try to think about how you store data
in individual tables. >>Okay.